I had the chance to visit the United
States Marine Corps one of their
training facilities
and they run an exercise called the lrc
the leadership reaction course it's
basically 20 mini problem solving
courses you know here's three planks of
wood of a different size you have to get
all your Marines and your material
across
the the little pod you know you know you
get the idea stuff like that and they're
timed
and because the Marine Corps has men and
women which they do it separately
they made a remarkable little uh they
made a remarkable little discovery
um men
fail very often
because they don't spend enough time
sharing ideas and planning they execute
too quickly because they're so driven to
win-win-win
and they don't have the right plan so
they fail
right
women
spent more time planning and very often
came up with the right solution but they
didn't leave enough time to execute so
they failed
and so it makes a case for Blended teams
and this is true about anything
which is the more
the more alternative Styles and
alternative perspectives we have
the more creativity we we bring to a
problem so male and female is obvious
did you grow up rich or poor
did you grow up in the north or the
South
you know did you grow up Muslim or Hindu
like all of these things will change
your point of view and how you see the
world and if we have different people
you know I know the cast structure the
cast structure is still somewhat alive
and well in India and I know there's
we're slowly trying to break it down but
people who grew up completely
differently from each other bring
different ways of seeing the world and
that makes a fantastic team
that makes a fantastic team when we have
different points of view because we have
different blind spots as well and
different ways of seeing the world so
inclusion to me is about all the
different ways in which people live
their lives I want them all on my team